one of the biggest mistakes people make
is telling their friends and family
about their YouTube channel and here's
why if you share one of your YouTube
videos with your friends and family
unless they happen to be just as
passionate about the topic they're into
that Niche and their YouTube consumers
them clicking on it and viewing and
subscribing is pointless and it could be
harmful because if your mom is like oh
honey you started a YouTube channel so
proud of you all subscribe and maybe
she's active on YouTube but all she
watches is Miniatures videos DIY videos
of like homemaking stuff how to make
good Arnold Palmer and lemonade and
where where are we the Masters and she
ultimately is like watching all this
stuff but she clicks on your gaming
channel and she's not into it then what
YouTube's always doing is it's trying to
group it's trying to identify what your
channel is about and who else will be
interested in your channel and they're
like wait a minute like moms that are
into Miniatures are also into this
gaming because because your mom's not
ultimately into your channel she's just
supporting you your friends probably
aren't consistent YouTube consumers
maybe and they're not into your channel
so actually the mistake people make is
sometimes they can promote their Channel
just to get vanity views or vanity
subscribers when they don't actually
attract people who find the channel on
its own merits or find it because
they're genuinely interested in the
topic itself so you're better
off doing two things number one
following the training I just taught and
creating search based content that
attracts people legitimately interested
in your content that are finding it
based on that interest you know like
there's no reason you're searching
Coleman
tents versus Northface tents if you're
not interested in tents and camping like
it would be pretty irrational that that
would be where you find yourself on
YouTube so now you know you're
attracting somebody that that's into
camping that's into Outdoors Etc so
that'd be a good subscriber potentially
and a good follow of your channel so
that's thing one thing two is when you
promote your videos I think it is good
to promote them in a polarizing way and
I what I mean by polarizing is like not
being afraid to say only only watch this
this video is only for um you know and
and here's a better way to say it if I
was promoting on X and Twitter and I
said I just uploaded a new video how to
grow your YouTube channel in 2024 that's
probably self filtering because if you
don't want to grow a YouTube channel in
2024 you probably wouldn't click on
it if I said how to grow a you know use
YouTube to get more leads and clients
for Real Estate also self- filtering
because if you don't do real estate and
you're not a real estate agent you
probably wouldn't click on it so that
would be fine to promote because your
mom's not like oh I'm gonna go check out
that real estate because she's not in
real estate but sometimes I will
verbally say or we'll say it in email or
in text we'll say like this is for you
if you are you're going to love this
video if you're a business owner that's
already doing over six figures a year um
because the clearer you are the the the
Creator who understands the viewer best
wins and so and if YouTube understands
your channel it'll help you win because
YouTube does want to associate you kind
of with keywords and Concepts and topics
to be like oh this is a street
photography channel so in summary if
your mom is passionate about street
photography then you should invite her
to your Channel about street photography
but in general I would not try to just
get views and subscribers from random
people in your life that are ultimately
just going to hurt the algorithm if you
enjoyed this content and want to take
your YouTube channel to the next level
just click or tap the link on the screen
or go to tube 1K challenge.com to join
our next live YouTube challenge you'll
learn our best tips and strategies that
are working here at think media and I
think you'll love it